hey how's it going this is Craig Cannon
and you're listening to Y Combinator's
podcast so today we have an uncut
interview from the Masters of scale
podcast and in it Reed Hoffman the
co-founder of LinkedIn interviews Sam
Altman all right here we go
so I'm here with Sam Altman president of
Y Combinator who is a good friend and
has been involved in many scaling things
let's start with your entrepreneurial
like what got you in entrepreneurship
how how you started lubed why you
started lubed yeah first of all thank
you for having me here I fell into it
accidentally I went to college to be a
computer programmer I knew that was all
I wanted to do and I started college
after the dot-com bubble had bust and so
startups were not anyone's mind in fact
it was I remember one of things I was
surprised by as a freshman in college
was that I thought people would still be
excited about startups and if you said
you were working on a start-up people
you sort of laughed at you in a not nice
way and I actually didn't want to work
on a start-up I worked my summer after
my freshman year and the Stanford CS
department as a researcher and I loved
that and out of that grew a project
which eventually developed into loped
but it started as just a project that we
worked on sort of like after class and
at night and it was not it would not
have been a start-up if it went on for y
combinator
so it kind of got to the point where we
had worked on it during a spring spring
quarter and it was really fun I'm very
ashamed to say that I had been planning
to go be an intern at Goldman Sachs that
summer I accepted a job offer and I
realized I was having much more fun
we're all three of us working on this
project and we all kind of knew who Paul
Graham was we had followed him online
and he posted this thing saying like hey
not excite about your summer job I like
come hack on your project and you can
make a startup and you know that seemed
like it would be more fun than
being an investment banker so we applied
to YC and flew out and interviewed and
got funded we actually first got me ever
funded by YC and that was how then I
just kept going and is there anything
that even this the very beginning is
there anything from now having done
looped and a bunch of things we're gonna
get into that if you could call that
younger self of yours going into YC that
you would tell yourself to do
differently like key things well I think
one general thing that I didn't
understand then and learn pretty quickly
but would have saved me quite a bit of
heartache is about how to calibrate risk
I think most people worry way too much
about risk you know when you're young
and you have nothing to lose is
absolutely the time to take risk and
it's the time unfortunately that most
people that most risk-averse in their
lives they need to save they just they
want to work for a few years build up
savings and they're gonna start up they
want to do what their parents want
whatever and I ended up in the right
place but it could have gone either way
and I was very totally stupidly nervous
about the risk and so this idea that
most things are not nearly as risky as
they seem
it's a powerful one and one that I
always try to tell people in that
position you know you're like a poor
college student with no money and no
reputation if you do a start-up and fail
you're like two years older with no
money no reputation and it's fine it's
actually much harder to wait and you
know let your life ramp up and then do
it so that's one thing I think another
thing is why don't anything I'm super
easy to work with today but I was like
sort of infamously difficult to work
with when I was 18 or 19 and I would
have put more effort into trying to be
better about that and what specifically
would you have done to be easier to work
with I think a lot of it is how you set
and communicate expectations with others
and also realizing that
if you're the founder of the company and
you want to work 100 hours a week
and be super focused and productive
that's cool but like most other people
you hire especially as you get bigger
have other lives and you need to
understand that again you everyone
learns this lesson quickly yeah but it
would have saved some you know pain
along the way if I had learned earlier
the and then the other thing that I
think I got wrong and nineteen-year-old
starting companies often get wrong is
because they evolve fairly organically
from projects you never take the time to
realize like wow this has become you
know all of a sudden they're running
this company with ten people when we're
doing this and we've raised all this
money and do I really believe that this
is going to be a market that will
support a giant company and I think
there is a check point where you need
several checkpoints along the way where
people don't get that on a thought and
how do you think about how how do you
think that they should make those
checkpoints because you know from other
conversations I know that both you and I
think this whole total addressable
market Tam thing is frequently very
illusory
yeah yeah I think you know the most
interesting companies start with a team
of nearly zero and it's like a very bad
investors are the ones that are super
focused on the Tam of today very good
investors are focused on the time of ten
years from now the the thing that I have
seen the most predictive for Tammuz
total addressable market the thing that
I have seen be most predictable for a
large Tam down the road is how much the
people that are using it today used it
and loved it so one of the things that
was obvious when people got iPhones even
though like you know they're only a few
million of the first iPhone sold them as
people who had them use them every day
and love them and it became like their
most precious item I remember shortly
after the iPhone came out I was in a
developing world country that was really
quite poor and people had nothing except
they all had a smartphone
and and and people that once they had
one like you know you read these
statistics and people need to do some
lightweight journalism about like would
you rather give up your smartphone or X
and it doesn't really matter what X is
they're going to keep the smartphone and
so I think you could have predicted with
a lot of certainty and many
complimenting people did that this was
going to be a large market it was small
in 2008 2007 but it was guaranteed that
was gonna grow very quickly because of
how much people loved it the Internet in
the early days was the same thing and I
think a lot of other trends people jump
on too early because a lot of people
dabble but put it on the shelf mmm-hmm a
lot of people have bought VR headsets
and then put them on the shelf doesn't
mean that VR will not be big someday but
this is I don't think you could make a
high conviction bet on starting a a V
our company today at least it that or at
least that the Tam will be huge it still
feels like we're at the the Palm Pilot
not the iPhone era for those who
remember Palm Pilots yeah you know I
have one still that I got when it was a
ridiculous thing to have a Palm Pilot 7
was the Internet connected one and I
loved it but other people didn't and I
thought that was sort of its you can it
was it's very easy to tell the
difference between the reaction to that
and the iPhone I think you probably know
this but you know the first use case for
PayPal was splitting the dinner check on
Palm Pilots I do know that and
apparently like legend had set it up so
that it could only happen once because
it was actually cryptographically secure
and he stayed up for four nights in a
row or something and this demo and the
camera didn't work and I went through it
again yeah and they only had two that it
worked on yeah it was kind of crazy and
they did part of the [ __ ] we did the
closing of the first financing on it in
box vegetating yes classic Silicon
Valley stuff so um so loops then how did
you get to YC so looked at it ran lived
for seven years
we got acquired and I was trying to
figure out what I went through next and
I decided I was going to partly take a
like a sort of mid-career sabbatical
race cars fire planes travel the world
all about kind of stuff
but then I want to totally disengage
from working and that I would try to
invest for a while so I took the money I
made from looped and I also raised some
outside capital and I became a sort of
very traditional seed investor I had
invested a little bit during during
looped a very small check so that was
possible and back in the day because the
the valuations were so much lower in the
company he's raised so much less money I
remember it like in 2000 and I guess was
2010 I invested in stripe and I had like
seventeen thousand dollars in my bank
account at the time in 2009 and I
invested like fifteen thousand that into
stripe and you know it's like for a
meaningful percentage of companies
there's a different world and that's
kind of like as a founder not making
much money kind of that was sort of the
size of cheque you could do but it was
still possible to like once a year make
an angel investment as a founder and now
I just think you can't because the
amounts of money and seiran's have gone
up so much but because it was a
different world I had invested a little
bit during loped I think I made three
investments and I thought I liked it so
I was like well I'm gonna do this as my
sabbatical job and I did that from 2012
to 2013 and I turned out to be fairly
good at it but I didn't like it at all
and I think you just have to try things
- no but it turned out that I don't want
to be a seed investor or a VC it I liked
running a company I did not like being
on the sidelines and it just I didn't
find I didn't get the adrenaline rush I
get out of sort of like being in the
trenches of running a company which i
think is something that a lot of
founders miss when they start investing
you know you figure out an approach this
I like for investors which is continue
to be very involved with operating one
company and I think that's a model that
is very under explored and we'll see
more off so um but anyway I did this and
I was like you know what that was fun
and
it's did pretty well I think it's like a
ridiculously highly compensated job and
sorry but I didn't want to keep doing it
um and I was thinking about things I
want to do in Paul Graham and sort of
jokingly said a number of times over the
years that I'm gonna retire and you
should take over YC and I had kind of
bucketed that in my head in the you know
this is investing
I don't like investing but I started
talking about that more seriously I was
looking at two other things I was gonna
Goldman Sachs no it's the thing about
going to run a big public company or
start a company I been excited about for
a while um and the more but I found like
I'm really gonna think hard about what I
want to do it and YC seemed like such a
promising and underutilized thing and so
important to what I cared about or at
least I realized that there was the set
of like four or five things that I
really deeply cared about and YC had the
best platform of anything I was looking
at or maybe anything in Silicon Valley
to go address all those and that even if
there are things about it that it wasn't
excited about I could get other people
to do those or I could change YC in big
ways and that worked out basically as I
expected which was great um go in a
little bit more details about what the
things were that was like oh here was
the because this is one of the things
where you see the potential scale like I
see this asset it could be so much more
in Silicon Valley and I want to go to
what were those so one was the kinds of
companies that we were funding I I had a
we were at the time YC was mostly
funding software companies but I had a
lot of conviction that we could apply
the same thing that made YC it work so
well for software companies to companies
in a lot of the areas that I cared about
and you know a ice technology energy and
at the same model would work which is
that now people are like oh yeah hard
tech everyone wants tumescent are
attacked by the time it was like this is
a really dumb thing one of the things
that is funny as a side note and just as
a note to anyone that
tries to do anything where you take a
company in a different direction or
scale it is that it is always funny to
sort of like read the articles from the
same journalists that when you say
you're going to do this thing say like
Sam is crazy
completely unqualified this is not gonna
work YC is gonna die like going after
hard tech enemies is so stupid to like a
year fourteen months later you know this
is great like Sam is genius it was like
predestiny was gonna take over YC you
know it's ridiculous that YC doing any
software companies all it's all that's
our stuff so I think you'd have to
ignore all of that and just say like I
have I love a conviction we're gonna try
this thing and most people will tell you
it's not gonna work if it's something
new
most people are afraid of things that
are new and you just do it and as long
as it's not again
risk is miscalibrated it's probably not
that risky probably won't kill the
company and probably undervalued if
everyone else does it's stupid so we
were able to do that and and the first
thing was expand YC into all these
different directions I think the
greatest companies are created on kind
of the bleeding edge of what people are
working on and by 2014 there were
already a lot of people making mobile
apps there will still be great mobile
app companies I'm sure but it was like
fish in a barrel and some of these other
areas we were able to just go pick out
in the world the best contravening
company the best self-driving company
which recent got acquired by GM the best
nuclear fusion company the best of the
technology company and just all the way
down the list and no one was competing
to invest in those companies meanwhile
like another photo sharing company we
have to like go do a lot of work to
convince him to do YC because they're
like well every VC and Santa road wants
to give me thirty million dollars so
that was one area where we expanded
another was just more companies we
significantly up the number of companies
we fund every year - what for example
maybe it was like from a hundred to two
eighty something like that now we expand
the geographies that we play a lot we
now fund companies from all over the
world which is a logistical nightmare
but it's really good for the kind of
couple
we can serve we raised a later stage
fund because one of the other things
realize especially with the hard tech
companies you know you can fund a lot of
these companies at some point they need
to raise 50 hundred million dollars not
a lot of investors are doing that so to
support those companies we needed this
large pool of capital we wanted to on
the other side really increase the top
of our funnel and so we started teaching
MOOCs basically say hey we're gonna like
try to distill how to start a start-up
thon to a class and make it available
around the world
we started a research lab there are some
things that are important to us and our
mission in our vision for the world that
don't fit as a for-profit company that
we still want to do but but basically
fundamentally YC is sort of this new
university we are a collection of smart
people that have some sort of shared
vision of the world we'd like to build
and the tools that we think work to get
there and that's a very flexible
structure so being able to do all these
things and in terms of the efforts to
scale YC is like this global geography
there's early in late-stage there's
research that you also you know taking
nonprofits through YC yeah well as part
of that when you think about and you say
okay I saw this potential I to have a
massive scale impact then I went in
which were the things that you kind of
wish you would double down on earlier
and which of the things that you would
have changed in that scaling process
we've kind of I think one thing that is
really the two things are really
important to get right when you're going
to try to scale an organization a lot
one is a very clear vision and culture
and the other is a reasonably clear org
structure I think we are good on the
division and culture you know this idea
that like YC wants to produce the most
innovation in the world and then do that
in such a way where we make the future
great for everyone not for seven people
and
and we've stayed we kind of talked to
when I took over about that to sort of
the mission the vision the culture to
support that and I think we've done a
very good job of staying true to that
and and like one thing I'm particularly
proud of the organization on us without
me having to legislate it if there's a
company we look at where we think we'd
make a lot of money but it'd be we think
it might be bad for the world we won't
touch it which most other investment
firms unfortunately a hard time with but
you know we do things that other
investment firms would not like fun
basic income research or support of an
eye or fun nonprofits and so I think we
got that right early and that and
getting that right it's really critical
because if everyone believes the same
thing there's a lot less conflict and
also if people are gonna kind of
organically march in the right direction
you just need a lot less organization
you just need some and I think we could
have put a better structure in place
earlier we've gone through a few
iterations I think we now have one
that's good but I initially tried to
sort of just have no structure at all
and the prop that would have worked if
we had stayed at like ten people working
at YC which is what it was when I took
over fall apart fell apart pretty
quickly at 30 40 people something like
that was it a deliberate intent did
halakhah see or was it just kind of like
oh let's try not bother with it was
definitely not a deliberate attempt at
holacracy which I don't think I'm a fan
of from what I know about it it was it
was just like it you know the growth in
the number of people of an organization
sneaks up on you and you can completely
get away without any structure until you
can't and it's a pretty quick flip okay
and what do you think about was there
anything you would have applied capital
to more fiercely or anything that you
would have said I should have recruited
these people into the organization
earlier
we run super light on capital and I
think that is to our credit so there are
all these things that would have been
smoother and better if we had applied
more capital to but the trade-off is it
would have hurt our culture and that
reflects on companies like I kind of
like that when entrepreneurs come to YC
they drive to like honestly a kind of
shitty industrial part of Mountain View
and they walk into this building that
looks like it's that we did a nice job
on the inside but it's like nice in the
very you've been that I have it's nice
and be very cheap sense like there's no
like gleaming marble or you know what
you see on Sand Hill Road a lot yeah and
we just like you know we still have like
a CFO that yells at people if she finds
that there was a fifty dollar cheaper
flight to buy and so in all of these in
all these specific instances we could
have applied more money to problems and
it would have helped but I think there
is something culturally important to us
about frugality because we want that
reflected in our startups and our
startups have the kind of bond with us
where they reflect what we do so I think
on the whole it is good we did not try
to go solve a bunch of problems by May
got lots of capital so let's go to the
YC selection process because we're gonna
go into what are the lessons from YC
companies and one of the things I
learned from The New Yorker profile
which I had no idea because I've never
seen it is that you occasionally bring a
sword in with you to interview an
entrepreneur no that's that's not true
that is so it well either they wrote
that wrong or no I I think I remember
what happened um I do like I I love
engineering history of all sorts I you
know kind of collect these things that
like Concorde engines and just like
things I think are important in
engineering milestones so I I I had
bought this Bronze Age sword and I was
in office hours and the reporter was
sitting with me and off
ours are kind of this drudgery that
sometimes where you doing this like you
know it's the 16th meeting of the day
and I needed some energy and so one was
a phone call and the store had just came
beautiful Bronze Age sword and and it
had just arrived I've been waiting for
this thing you know like I flown over
from Europe and it was in this big crate
and it got it out it was stunning
perfect and I mean the first thing you
do is like pick it up and swing it and
see like how its weighted how it feels
and this particular one it had like like
you know like the nicks of where it hit
people's helmets a couple thousand years
ago was a little dark but or maybe bones
too much of a nick pheromone don't do
too deep of a Nick in the middle and so
I was like so excited and I I was on the
phone with and it was kind of like a not
particularly exciting conversation and
so I picked it up when we were like in
my house and I just started like while I
was on the speakerphone like swinging it
around and like fighting this pretendin
at me because I was so happy I just got
this I'd been waiting for it for so long
and I didn't realize till I put it down
at the end but like that was real
probably really dominant probably gonna
make it into the profile because a
report was sitting there watching kind
of just forget after someone's way
through four weeks but I have never
swung a sword at someone during every
process if it was less the swinging a
sword and more did you like bring props
with you to the interview no no this was
just in my house and I had just arrived
we don't bring props got it so tell me a
little bit about the YC interview
process this is one of the things you've
actually really refined over the years
in order to get really good yeah um
there are a few big ideas that actually
a very small number of big ideas that
make YC work and one of them is that the
there is a giant amount of arbitrage
left because most investors in Silicon
Valley will only fund you with an intro
or they'll only talk to you with an
intro and it is honestly I think by and
large a fairly insular Network and one
of the ideas with YC is if we can build
a process that's not too painful well we
can look at everyone's smart that wants
funding from us
that we can unlock a huge amount of
value because no one else does that or
at the time anyone else did that now
other people do it but I don't think
they do it as well we have a brand or
something where I think we still have an
edge but you know we are able we are
willing we are willing to look at tens
of thousands of people a year with
knowing show they don't know us and
there's a lot of really smart people
that just because of the circumstance
they were born into or the country or
whatever don't aren't plugged into the
Silicon Valley Network and we are a
bridge to that and I think we get
compensated for that but that idea that
you should have an open application and
you don't shouldn't require an intro
it's great now doing it well in practice
is hard because it is very tiring and
very draining to talk to 40,000 people a
year so we have a lot of people a lot of
software we this is like a secret I
don't even mind telling something other
people will copy it well we spent so
much time and money building really
great internal software but only like 50
people in the world use and yet it lets
us run this process that no one else can
run and you videotape them and you cross
check the result yeah we crushed your
results we watch you know companies that
we say yes or no to we when we say yes
to a company we have to say how strong
yes it is how well we think you're going
to do and we really sweat every mistake
and so tell me also before we get to the
some of the interesting companies about
your going global efforts like what were
the things the scale to more than just
the Silicon Valley Network well the
number one best thing we did for that
was the the the MOOC the class that we
teach that got incredible distribution
worldwide and then that brought people
from these other countries and what we
find is that when we fund someone from
another country or city for the first
time they go back and everybody else
there is like well I can get into I see
now it's not so hard and so we just see
this there's like this uh you know
there's like this there's this
incredible chain reaction effect once we
get the first good company in a new area
we also do get on planes a lot you know
like partners just go fire on the world
and give talks
meat companies and that is phenomenally
effective it won't be too much longer
until we have more companies applying
from outside the US than inside the US
and they also were doing a Fellows
Program at some point yes we it was sort
of like an on-ramp version to YC one of
the things we realized that there was
more demand for that program than we
were ever gonna fill we were shocked how
we're gonna get like 200 applications
for the first fellowship got like 7,000
no no this is not gonna work as designed
so we have now evolved that and the
class that we've taught together into
this new thing that we're gonna try next
year for the first time which is halfway
between lecture series and Y Combinator
class where people have individual
advisors and office hours and after a
point their metrics every week but they
can do it remotely and anyone can do it
so now let's go to a couple of the kind
of great you know just amazing YC
companies so there's a number we talked
about stripe a little earlier as one of
your earlier yesterday I think you now I
actually hadn't realized the background
economics I think you now you were more
edgy in your angel investor than I was
because I started pretty early with kind
of the crazy like how much are your
savings but I think you had a higher
percentage of your savings that you were
deploying risk management has never been
my strongest suit yeah so I think I went
up to 50 percent not I think that was
roughly somewhere around 90 different
when you have no money at all though
like yeah I mean it's just some level
beyond which the percentage doesn't
matter yeah
and so let's so let's talk about a few
of them and what are the key kind of
lessons for how the scaling like what we
have learned and what common here in
Silicon Valley what how to scale let's
start with stripe where obviously that
Carlson's are amazing and the company is
doing spectacularly well like what did
it look like in the early days why did
you think it'd be great what did they
learn about how to scale so I think the
number one lesson that I have learned or
that YC has learned about how to scale
well is that the first thing you have to
do is build a product that is so good
people
containing this you want to use it and
tell their friends about it and if you
can do that you still have to blitzscale
but it's the easy kind it's you have too
much demand the hard kind of
blitzscaling
is where you you you you try to start
scaling up before the product is really
great and then most of your effort in
scaling is to generate demand so I think
the number one most important insight
about how to blitz scale is that the
good kind of blitz scaling is when you
are not having to generate demand as you
go but that you first got the product
right and in many of these cases stripe
Dropbox Airbnb they took a long time to
get the product right but they were
obsessed with that and then when they
did all their effort is okay
we have so much demand that without much
more effort we know this is gonna keep
growing 20 30 percent a month for years
that's a real problem it's a high-class
problem but it's still a real problem
how do we build that so that is the kind
of scaling that works and it has
generated Facebook Google I mean a lot
of it's the same playbook um I think the
kind of blitzscaling that we have seen
go badly is we have a mediocre product
we have raised hundreds of millions of
dollars and our vc is beating down our
throats to hire more salespeople to grow
faster any any particular examples I
don't want to name names there's so many
to pick from thankfully most of them are
not YC the one thing that is pretty good
and again a few exceptions to this we
try to beat that idea out of people
during YC and thus most of the people
mistakes in Silicon Valley of that sort
in the last decade if not worse one
interesting thing that I think is a
slight variant on the theory that you
just gave that applies to every and B is
actually in fact one of the things I
think I've learned about some scaling
things is that you initially have to do
things that don't scale in order to get
into scaling and so actually in fact
they spend a bunch of time kind of out
in the desert not getting transactions
and I think it was actually Paul Graham
who gave me this and I said look go to
New York go door-to-door explain to
people just get them into it yeah Paul
Graham wrote an essay out of that
experience and a striped experience is
someone we can talk about an essay is
called do things that don't scale I
think is in the top four most important
essays for a new founder to read the
this is almost universal among not
perfectly but almost universal among our
best companies where initially you have
to go get users manually or do things
that you could never do with 10 million
users and it's actually a sign of bad
entrepreneurs in my experience when
people that have a company with no users
no product in no revenue say they won't
do something because well that's not
going to scale um it's what that means
is I am lazy and don't want to go get my
hands dirty or I think knocking on doors
and taking photos is below me in the
Airbnb guys this case um which is not
what they did they actually went and did
all those thing exactly exactly so I
think the way that you build a really
great product is to be very close to
your customers and the way that you do
that is to do things that don't scale
and so I think it's super important I
think it's again like a critical piece
of still even in 2016 in Silicon Valley
still not fully internalized advice are
there any cases that come to mind for
you that where someone built a really
good product that had that kind of at
least potential for love that actually
failed the scale
you know Twitter is the example everyone
uses and they say well if the company
had scaled better it would have been a
two hundred billion dollar company not
twenty billion dollar company or what a
ten or whatever it's worth now um and if
like if Twitter is the best example you
can find if it's not working that still
says something and there are others it's
more often where I think the founders
were really good at building a product
but then not good at all building a
company so it never even got far into
the public conscious but it's rare it
happens surprisingly rarely what advice
do you give YC founders on hiring to
scale Vinod Khosla has this sound byte
that I have always loved all right which
is that the team you build is the
company you build and a lot of founders
particularly young founders but a lot of
founders are afraid to hire people that
are a lot more competent or experienced
than they are and there's some truth to
this because a lot of times hiring
really experienced people backfires and
I should try not to be good at all but
it can be magic when it works right and
the thing that I think you need most to
scale well and quickly is two or three
senior team members that you trust and
that are really good at scaling an
organization especially if you're a
first time CEO so the recipe I think has
worked pretty well in Silicon Valley is
a relatively inexperienced CEO who
identifies a small number of direct
reports who are really great it's
getting things up pretty quickly and
know how to do that and if you don't
hire those people generally I think you
kind of just will suffer and do you and
YC teach the companies anything about
culture building not enough
we've we do do some of that in the early
days which I think we're fairly good at
but there's a lot of culture building is
not this thing that you do in the first
three months of your life and then stop
which it gets a lot more important as
the company gets well out of YC one of
the things that we're thinking about
doing it YC is programs to continue to
teach our founders more well after out
of YC the model used to be that you
would go through YC and then you get a
board member who would only take you
know eight boards and would spend a
couple days a month with you and do
things like help you build the culture
as the company scales but just the
dynamic of Silicon Valley venture has
changed so much and people there's so
many more companies and more deals per
investor that I think a lot of these
things that used to get taught 1-1 by a
board member now I just don't get taught
at all and so I'm interested in in terms
of what we can do to teach that to to
our alumni one thing I think you said
during a Stanford seminar is what a
founder needs is something like idea x
product x execution times team x luck yo
is there any particular work work site
where luck is a random number between
zero and ten thousand is there anything
in particular you think that you should
that people should keep in mind about
how to play luck how to make luck how to
how to factor luck into the strategy
yeah I look I think there are a lot of
ways that you can manipulate the outcome
and there's a lot of things you can do
unrelated to luck and certainly you can
be really lucky but if you don't do the
other thing as well company will still
be worth nothing or very little um but I
think all those are things like try to
come up with a really good idea and
trying to pick a markets gonna be really
big and trying to hire a great team and
trying to execute really well like those
are all the wages you minimize the
effect of luck that said there's just
like it's a chaotic universe so sure I
think you can do a whole lot to minimize
that and you should I think I also I
also generally believe that if you do
really well on those four categories
even if the first
the second company doesn't work out you
can kind of tell people that are
eventually gonna be successful at
something and it takes a lot of tries
yeah if they keep at it especially yeah
one of the things I think is a the way
that I think about managing luck is like
one of those YC provides founders which
is really good is a network and it's the
use of the network both for seeking
opportunity and also seeking risk
assessment right like what do you think
you know like one of the pieces of
advice I give founders is to constantly
go to smart people and say what do you
think what land mines might have run to
what risks might I have not just do you
like my thing or not because I'm sitting
with you I'm probably I say are you sure
your things great unless I'm you know
deliberately trying to help you by being
edged what do you think about those as
as key things for luck management yeah I
agree I think that you know the way I
have always tried to think about it for
myself is that luck is a big factor but
I'm going to keep working and eventually
you know because it's a random variable
it's gonna swing my way and I think
that's roughly the right mindset to have
if you don't acknowledge the role of
luck at all like I think you're wrong in
a dangerous way where you sort of just
are not a great human and if you can't
look at I got really lucky at some
points it's probably bad but if you're
also like well it's all about luck and
you know I have no chance the world is
against me and I'm just gonna sit here
and complain that's not gonna work
either so I think the other roughly
correct mindset is luck is important but
I'm eventually gonna get lucky and I'm
gonna just work really hard and tide you
that may be the one of the better
definitions of optimism that actually I
think I've heard good so a little bit of
the one of the challenges of being the
president of a scale thing is that all
of a sudden of demands on your time go
ferocious alright so for example you get
a deluge of email looking for meeting
requests how do you manage that
I don't think it's rude to send someone
an email asking him to meet I also don't
think it's rude not to respond or to
write it quick
thanks but I'm just super busy I don't I
still think I'm Angelus well because I
still feel more guilty than I said about
not doing things but I try to be pretty
rigorous about not doing what I don't
want to do um I think everyone finds
their own productivity systems that work
well for them I'm a lists person so I
make lists every day of what I need to
get done and I make like anulus to the
big picture things I want to do and I
you know because YC is a services
organization I've just accepted them
gonna be very interrupt-driven and then
most of my time is going to be
dynamically responsive to our companies
that need help and I just accept that I
I'm gonna that's our fundamental job I'm
gonna you know devote 50 to 60 percent
of my time to that and I just leave it
empty cuz I don't know when it's gonna
come up but other than that I I just
don't do stuff I don't want to do and I
think this is an under utilized strategy
because it feels rude and again I still
because I feel don't do nearly as good
of a job of it as I would like I think
the other answer that no one likes to
give is just work a lot just do a lot of
hours I you know you can people talk
about working smarter all they want
there's nothing that makes up for like
working smarter and a lot of hours yep
what got you into coding I don't
remember not being into coding honestly
I mean I like I got a computer for my
eighth birthday and I already knew how
to program it very rudimentary
programming so I learned at some point
before that at school but I don't
remember it was just yeah the The New
Yorker thought it was analyzing area
codes uh I mean New Yorker writers home
for live series I don't think are
particularly right no one yeah
got it because I was curious what that
was in the category of things I didn't
know in addition to the amateur
swordsman I
I um you know like I think I have a
brain that is naturally inclined to
enjoy things like puzzles and math and
coding is like a fun way to do that and
then for the last personal question of
this sort many people have noted you
have an affinity for cargo shorts I'm
not wearing them today I know hold
outside yes so when it's warm cargo
shorts and is there any particular
reason cargo shorts honestly I don't
think they're doubt ugly and I find an
incredibly convenient like I you can
like put a lot of stuff like I like to
i'd still be paperback books I like
paperback books I like to carry on
around with me I have like a iPhone 7
plus which is kind of like works really
well in cargo pockets I carry like
computer chargers cables they're just
like you know efficient why people care
about that so much I can't tell you I
don't know either but it's it's somewhat
your Batman utility belt yeah you just
can't carry a lot of stuff there okay so
moving back to back to blitzscaling and
the scaling you know you and I have
talked a bunch about what are the kind
of theories of what makes Silicon Valley
unique is this networks of talent and
networks of practice in order to do this
scale things quickly and some of that is
to actually build a product that
actually goes you know fairly global
pretty quickly is there anything in the
theories that I've been doing that you
think I currently have a hole in well
good luck because you're familiar with
the whole range is there anything you
would critique the current blitzscaling
theory well I certainly agree incredibly
strongly that the magic of Silicon
Valley is the dense network of people
that have this knowledge these
connections the willingness to help for
free
and just all of you know the network is
so dense that all the different pieces
you need of which there are a lot to
blitzscale are all together and if I
disagree with anything it would be how
quickly that will spread outside of
Silicon Valley I think it may happen
relatively quickly so there's still a
question of how long there's still a
question of how long does Silicon Valley
remain the absolute dominant force in
startups and I think at this point a lot
of that knowledge and talent and people
in capital and cultural mind share
whatever is seeping out and wait I think
is good and so I don't know if it's
against the theory but it would at least
suggest a relative weakening of Silicon
Valley so let me let's let's do one more
version of this a hanket useful so the
central theory is say actually in fact
part of what Silicon Valley itself has
his network effects or its network
effects of the Talent Network effects a
knowledge sharing Network effects of of
company and business formation and so
therefore creating another Silicon
Valley or other Silicon Valley's is
actually super difficult because you
need to have that network effect density
in order to make it happen and your
counter theory is actually in fact that
the networks are actually being built in
those places because the culture of
entrepreneurship is spreading yes or
that they yeah I think it's just
spreading and do you think that the
question of like scale talent and the
ability to kind of play the scale games
is sufficiently spreading well I think
if you like look at Beijing it's
spreading there yeah although actually
China is its own case there's
blitzscaling the Silicon Valley whose
blitzscaling in China maybe LA is more
interesting case la is not Silicon
Valley it feels like one of the things
I've always said that make Silicon
Valley work is that startups are the
number one thing in New York it's
finance and DC in politics in LA it's
been media
and it's still definitely not startups
but it's interesting that startups
there's a number of startups in LA
snap most probably but others that are
doing really well in fact I bet there's
more billion plus dollar companies in LA
in the last few years than New York or
at least more total market cap and it's
not that as LA has not been
traditionally thought of as a hotspot
for startups at all at all and yet
somehow well everyone was talking about
New York is the second Silicon Valley I
think there's more evidence at other
cities
LA Seattle and I think that's kind of an
interesting example of where it was
close enough or it is close enough that
people fly back and forth all the time
they move you can get people to move
from Silicon Valley down to LA and at
this point I'd say you have that
whatever that is that density of network
in talent and capital and knowledge and
everything else in LA and I have
relatively quickly I said that part of
the network extension because when I
think about how to build more Silicon
Valley's it's the connectivity of
Silicon Valley which is one of the
things I think YC does so well actually
a part of how you get it to spread for
sure so I'm gonna go to lightning round
let's is anything else something that's
in your pocket besides your phone very
often nothing honestly I I have been
trying to evolve down to just a phone I
still carry like one credit card in Mike
I driver's license sometimes but very
often nothing but if I'm artificial
intelligence fills you with hope or
dread pick one hope your favorite place
to think big
I'm pretty happy on any hike I don't I
don't think big in an office very well
although sometimes I guess I look at the
biggest ideas in the last few years my
office at home works bro I think I like
managed to get the feeling of a go and
getting the feeling of a good office
down is really important for good
thought and I think I found
managed to do it at my house like and I
think people get this wrong all the time
like what you actually want is a small
this is a famous uh I think it's a
DaVinci observation but variation is
like a small office with really good
natural light and you know comfortable
chairs and I finally got that um but I'm
a big hiker and I like being out by
myself or with friends but wait away
from like any structures I'm just
beginning because we moved headquarters
at LinkedIn to actually condition the
office I want and it's gonna have a lot
of custom wood when I get there and out
there yet when I do I'll have you come
over but it's to give it the tactile
feel um I I saw what I thought recently
was the perfect office which was a
Japanese teahouse basically with
beautiful custom wood in a by itself in
a forest so glass wood you know a couch
the table that was it perhaps post ranch
in alright what job would you take if
you were out of work tomorrow I would
just sleep for a while if I were out of
work tomorrow and do not think about
work um but you know a few months later
I shall go study physics and then I
would get some job related to that
probably I don't know one object from
your childhood that you could never
throw away
wash a lot of those um probably
photographs honestly but asked um I like
original computer and like the stuffed
animal I slept with when I was a kid and
I don't think I get throw away those
either
what's one question no one has ever
asked you I don't know if there's an
interesting one what's the one
outstanding talented job candidate that
got away someone that I was gonna hire
mm-hmm
well in our line of work it's more like
that you know most of the people the job
candidates are founders that we didn't
fund and that's actually what keeps me
up at night it's not even the famous
ones like we had not many times but
there have been a few times where we
funded someone and they went on to
really well but that's not the
interesting feeling about to me
interesting failure mode to me is people
that we said no to that would have been
the next Zuckerberg or Chesky or
whatever and there are three or four
people over the years that I have turned
down at interviews that didn't go on to
do anything successful but it still eats
at me and I'm pretty sure I was wrong in
a big way the one thing you wish your
phone could do
I wish there was sufficiently good AI on
my phone that it would only interrupt me
for things I needed to see and I could
say and it like and also that it would
decide if reading something would make
me more or less happy which probably
would means it would never show me
anything on Twitter that would be an
easy one but there's a lot of other
stuff where I think like I would love it
if it would curate what I saw better
favorite app Gmail probably actually the
new Gmail app sucks told you no but I
would say all-time favorite book oh
that's a hard one
well I can't pick one all-time favorite
book my favorite book of the year is a
book called pandemonium which is
basically I see methought I was
something like the coming of the Machine
Age from 1650 to 1850 and it was just
what it was like when people who had
never seen a machine before had to think
about the future of automation and
incredible read best movie ever
I'm not a huge movie person um I love
all the Star Wars movies I love dark
night I love the American Beauty to pick
something that it's not a sci-fi movie
I'm not I'm not huge movie watcher messy
desk or clean desk I don't really do a
desk I work on a couch most of the time
no desk
is there a single poem or passage from
literature that you've memorized I
memorize a lot of poems a lot of
literature the you know one image that I
love that is relevant to this
conversation there's a poem called
Ozymandias by Shelley and the image is
one that I think I often share with
founders of a certain type and it has
been very effective in correcting bad
behavior so I will use that one in the
desert is this wreckage of a statue this
giant statue of a king that is now
fallen in its ruins and it's all by
itself just in sand and the inscription
that's still visible on statue is my
name is Ozymandias king of kings look on
my works ye mighty and despair and there
are a lot of startup founders who in the
moment feel like they are the most
important thing ever in the world their
company is going to be incredible these
are usually founders that accomplish
nothing
and that have this feeling of like
forever I'm gonna be the most important
person my [ __ ] is maybe the most
important company we're going to be a
huge success and you know I'm King of
Kings look at my work and despair and
what eventually happens to everyone is
that you end up in ruins but startups
often do that pretty quickly and it's a
pretty quick change of fortunes and I
think keeping that image of like someday
when any any statement you make
like that is someday going to be in a
collapsed statue in a desert has been an
effective mental image for startup
founders that get way too arrogant
that's great actually I may use it too
the single greatest embarrassment of
your career I can't pick why I mean
there's so many that one of the things
that is good and bad about investing in
startups is deeply humbling
people forget that every time you make
an investment you do it with a belief
that that company is going to be
successful or at least that you're
paying for positive expected value and
so many investments that I have been so
confident about have utterly failed and
I'm so completely wrong that doesn't
actually bother me that much the painful
one is the other kind of error where
you're like no no this company's gonna
suck and then it goes on to be really
successful in the most painful version
of that of all for me is when I'm
already an investor in the company they
asked me to put more money into a future
round and I say the price is too high
and I'm not gonna do it and that's
happened many many times but that is
those are the most embarrassing errors
to me what are the techniques that you
teach YC founders on triage because one
of the key things is to let certain
fires burn while you're solving others
because the you know startups are
inherently dead at the beginning right
and what do you teach them about you
know kind of how do you go okay it's
totally fine to let those fires burn
while you're working on the other ones
so I think I like to draw the matrix of
urgent not urgent important not
important and everyone gets urgent
important first and non urgent not
important last that people screw up the
other two and so I like to talk about
you know the that you have to let the
urgent and not important things not
happen or get someone else to do them I
think a lot of founders find someone on
their team
relatively early on that they rely on
this and just like take care of that
stuff and never think about it
so I think that's one important frame of
mind I think another one is you only
have to do really well at a few things
to do well and you can do badly at a lot
of things but if you don't do well at
those few things it doesn't matter how
well you do everything else and so what
you don't want to be as the founder that
gets everything but building a great
product perfect and and so you just have
to ruthlessly prioritize is this going
to do it or not and you want to be aware
of the areas where people likely get
tricked so like going to conferences
going to like Necker Island or something
you know these things into being huge
time wasters and they and but they feel
they're fun and they superficially feel
like important networking or something
so we try to talk to people about here
the normal tricks founders fall for that
are bad uses of time great well thanks
Sam as always a huge pleasure and thanks
for talking with thank you all right
thanks for listening so as always you
can see the transcript at blog y
combinator com
and if you'd like to hear more from
masters of scale you can find them at
masters of scale com
see you next time
you